scp-173 vs scp-049  the sculpture versus the plague doctor  who would win the plague doctor kills  with a touch but 173 doesn't seem to be  alive in the traditional sense at all so  could 049 technically kill 173 outside  of 049's touch of death he has no real  combat skills it could leverage against  173 049 is also capable of sleep  implying it likely has eyelids making it  vulnerable to 173 and we all know what  happens if you even so much as blink  when looking at 173 if you are  unfamiliar then this next point is for  you  scp-049 also has a neck and well simply  put blink then snap personally we think  that scp-173 and its spine splintering  desires is the clear victor here